i want to start with i've seen the seven
episodes of season two already uh that i
got access to and they're real good i
laughed out loud a number of times that
uh oh cool thanks it's really good i'm
gonna actually say that i did enjoy it
more than the first season um yeah i
don't know if that matters to you at all
but um i really enjoyed it um
well i've mostly most of the things that
i've worked on um you know
people say that they they always
seem to say like well first see but then
i really liked it and i i kind of think
that that's partly
um a feature of character comedy because
you don't really know who the characters
are in the beginning and the jokes are
coming from who the characters are often
so
once you learn oh that's
typical
you know
tony
scara peducci joke then you kind of
appreciate it more but the other thing
is
that
we uh
steve and i were very much
in the mind of not making it like the
office in the beginning um
we were trying to make it very cinematic
and
what happened uh when we stopped the
first season was we we sat down and he
was like well
that wasn't that much fun to make it
that cinematic because
when you're when you're shooting
something like a movie
especially when you're really caring
about the look of it
there's a lot of down time while they're
lighting
and
you know
the thing that steve was is so brilliant
at and was used to from the office is
the ability to kind of improvise with
the other actors and you know afterwards
we looked at our
sort of what we had to work with and we
were like well
the cast is amazing the cast that we've
assembled for space force
it's a shame to you know make them
just shoot one side and then wait and
re-light you know what i mean as opposed
to like having a more flexible shooting
pattern where they can play off each
other and have fun with it and improvise
and so um in addition to norm hiscock
the other big creative change we did was
we brought in the guy who
directed the pilot of the office in a
lot of our biggest episodes uh this guy
ken kwapis
and
yeah and he's
so much about protecting
the performance energy on the set you
know for the cast so that they can relax
and not worry about the mechanics of
shooting it and um and he's also
super good at shooting comedy um
which is somewhat different than the
sort of
uh like
kubricky kind of thing we were going for
season one right so um
yeah so we kind of you know we we saw
what was working we we tried to fix it
so i'm glad you like it because i think
it came out great this season i i
legitimately laughed out loud a few
times um so when when you went into
netflix to you know to sell the idea or
they bought it did they ask you like do
you have a three-year plan do you have a
five-year plan or were they sort of like
we just want to be in business with you
and we believe in you and steve
uh well this was a weird one because um
uh steve and i had been
uh having lunch and saying you know be
fun to do something else work together
on a comedy again but we didn't have an
idea and then he went in to take a
meeting at netflix and um
uh they presented him with the idea of
doing something about space force
and um
so he called me and he said what about
something about space force because that
just got announced
and
one of the things i always wanted to do
was to do a military comedy because it's
like a genre
that
hasn't been on the air in a while and
um
so i i thought it was a great idea to do
it uh
and so then we kind of
built the show you know but the the
initial suggestion was actually a guy
named blair federer who's a
executive at netflix
uh the season two trailer that we're
going to premiere on collider it sells
the fun
and it shows some of this the gags if
you will but it doesn't it doesn't
reveal too much about the storyline so
what do you actually want to tell fans
about season two
well i think the the big picture is that
we are concentrating on the gags more it
is
more about these scenes the comedy
scenes between the cast
and i think the stories are more
personal and they're interesting and
you know
uh but
i don't think the
point of the show so much is
um
you know like a highly arched thing you
know what i mean it's kind of like each
episode is a fun adventure with these
with this cast and there's a loose
structure to it
i guess the big structure this year is
that with the new administration the
space force is much more underdogs
because people are super skeptical of
them in the new administration so uh we
have a guest star tim meadows who's the
new secretary of defense
and you know he's
he's making it hard for
uh the guys at space force so that's
that's the overall theme
um i steve wrote the season two episode
one and i'm just curious was it
something like how did that get figured
out did he say to you i'm just going to
write the first episode or did you guys
talk and how does that get worked out
um well uh
like i said there was a sort of a
post-mortem period where he and i sat
down and we said well what was working
how do we change things to
improve the experience and
i think he
um
i'm not we didn't have that many of the
same writers we had a few same writers
um
but we've got a bunch of new writers and
i think he kind of wanted to show the
writer's room what he was going for
in terms of tone so um
so he took the first one
the season one and i believe season two
are both ten episodes how does that
number get figured out is that coming
from netflix is that coming from you
guys
um actually season two is seven episodes
you saw the whole scene i saw the whole
thing well i mean it was a bit
challenging because we shot the first
season
in los angeles
before covid and we shot the second
season like at the height of covet in
vancouver right so
it was it was a different
um
uh process and i think seven episodes
was good because
you know we were able to
i i think pull them off at a high level
and
you know avoid a shutdown and
you know
it was probably as much as we could do
under the under the circumstances i'd
say the first season the episodes were
like 35 minutes each and a lot of season
two the episodes are more like 25
minutes they're a little shorter was
that uh was that as a result of covid or
was that a result of like how did you
sort of get like because it is a it's a
different feeling
yeah well you know it is a different
feeling these are very smart questions
um i'll say that one of the
ways that we
refocus the show on the cast was
that we explored a lot of the
ways that the the main serious regular
cast could interact with each other and
i think that um
season one that you know which is
appropriate because you're establishing
who the cast are and they don't all know
each other or like each other in season
one
you know so you have a lot more stuff
where
characters are outward facing um if you
know what i mean like they're uh
you know like i don't know
uh
you know angela's story is uh going to
the moon you know and she's uh with a
whole bunch of astronauts and it's
you know she's her individual story is
that and someone else has a different
individual story like
um
now i think more of the stories are the
various
cast members relating to other cast
members so
uh you can kind of
handle it in a shorter period of time
lisa kudrow was a bigger part of season
one she's part of season two but she's
not like a focal point if you will um at
least in my mind um was there a reason
for that that you you she's included but
she's sort of you know what i mean yeah
well again i think it i think she's
included in a fun way
she's not one of the series regulars
like the others so we spent more time
with them and part of that was coveted
too because
you know
um
the rules in canada required a certain
amount of quarantining and so to have
somebody show up and leave and then show
up and leave and everything it's just
too too much
um
uh for if you weren't a series regular
so uh
you know so we we
she's definitely in the show and she's
super funny but um
you know i think we would
probably
try to get her more for a season three
where we we had an easier
shoot
probably
i i completely get it have you guys
changed do you still have the same
reason as to why she's in prison or have
you changed that at all
we haven't changed the backstory on what
happened to put her in prison um
there's a scene where um
aaron diana silvers tells patton oswalt
who's
somebody up on a mars probe uh
she tells him the whole story of why
why she's in prison but we we don't
necessarily tell the audience
[Laughter]
exactly um what
when in the writing process knowing that
you were going to be dealing with covid
knowing you're going to be shooting in
vancouver
how did
that impact the writing in terms of you
know you were maybe we're coming up with
ideas of things you wanted to do and
then you realized wait we can't do that
like we're going to be we really need to
be thinking about being on soundstage
and not going on location too often or
whatever that may be
well um i wouldn't say we really changed
the writing for kobit that much but
we were changing the writing for the
fact that
it was a new administration and
so
space force was not being given all of
the resources that
they got in season one um
you know and uh
and they were more underdogs and so
what that led to was it was slightly
less busy in the halls which was good
for covid because
you know like having tons of extras
walking in and out is is wasn't great so
um
but that was part of the creative
refocusing too was to to refocus it on
our amazing cast and less on extras and
spectacle
uh which all was fine for coven